hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Civil War 2 video if you don't
know what that is it's a comic book
event but I'm gonna be talking about
Captain America's Civil War because
there's some similar things going on so
careful for spoilers from that movie as
well as the first Civil War if you
haven't been reading comics for the last
couple of years because Marvel's movies
have been so successful they're kind of
leading the cart now in terms of comic
book stories so even though the comics
are separate from the movies a lot of
the energy of the comics flows from
what's going on in the movies so they
did a big Captain America Civil War
movie big billion-dollar earning movie
naturally they're gonna try and find a
reason to have a civil war in the comics
so the first issue just dropped and as
they've been marketing this it's
basically Captain Marvel against Iron
Man they're like the two different teams
in this I'll be getting into story
details are just spoilers from that
first comic - so most of you know a long
time ago comic book civil war was team
Iron Man vs. team cap that's kind of
what they did in the movie this time
there is a funny joke about it they
definitely acknowledge it Iron Man's
like I'm not gonna get into it with you
Steve we've been down this road before
did not end well the first time the big
point of contention from the first Civil
War was the superhero Registration Act
in the movies they turned that into the
sokovia accords this time around it's
completely different they try to raise
the stakes while at the same time trying
to give you a good idea for why each
side chooses their position giving them
rational reasons for being at odds with
each other so during the first Civil War
Iron Man was a bit of a dick he's a
little more sympathetic he's almost like
the Captain America of this Civil War
just in terms of his characterization
Captain Marvel almost comes away in this
first issue looking like the antagonist
like she's the one that made the bad
call and led to terrible terrible things
happening so at least they're not making
Iron Man a dick again and full context
if you guys didn't read Secret Wars they
completely rebooted their universe Iron
Man for instance they took away a lot of
Iron Man's money and now he's running
the all-new all-different Avengers it's
almost like those stories where
Wolverine gets paired with a bunch of
children and he gets to be Papa
Wolverine so he's a little more
sympathetic but he's still kind of
hardcore that's kind of what's going on
with Iron Man they softened him quite a
bit so he's not in full-on dick mode
he's not like the man of this issue
Captain Marvel is the one working for
the big agency with all these
responsibilities
these problems she's trying to solve so
a solution comes up in this seeming
solution to all their problems is the
reason for civil war - like the whole
reason they're gonna be at odds because
there's a new Minority Report in human
and if you've never seen that movie
Minority Report it's all about people
being able to predict the future so you
try to use that to prevent crimes so
Ironman cautions against the
self-fulfilling prophecy you see
something terrible that might come to
pass in the future so you take steps to
avoid it but in doing so you bring that
event about self-fulfilling prophecy
he uses this really hilarious example
let's say there's a guy here comes
running up to us and says oh my god I
just saw a vision of the hook making out
with Ultron and a baby popped out in
that baby ends up being a reincarnated
Hitler so one it would be the world's
ugliest baby but to sidenote the thing I
love about this is I love the way he
tacks on Hitler baby at the end of that
as if a baby between Hulk and Ultron
would be a totally okay thing we don't
want to stop this baby from being born
but if it's gonna turn into Hitler then
we need to stop it so like the best
homework you can do for this in addition
to like reading all the supporting
titles that are going on right now is
rewatch Minority Report because as you
can imagine trying to avoid events in
the future that might end up happening
always leads to disaster so Ironman
takes a hard pass on trying to use this
new inhuman to stop potential crimes
where as Captain Marvel who has like the
weight of the world on her shoulders her
job is very literally protecting the
earth from outside threats in the whole
set up for this is this amazing action
set piece at the beginning of the comic
where a celestial being comes from
another dimension and is destroying the
earth but the combined forces of all the
heroes in all of Earth's magic users led
by Doctor Strange are able to banish it
back to its dimension but it's because
this new Minority Report inhuman so
everyone's celebrating like oh man that
was such a close call how did we know to
be there in time then we learn about the
new Minority Report Ulysses how he can
predict events in the future and that's
where it all starts to go sideways so a
lot of you will probably recognize
visual callbacks - the first version of
Civil War subtle verbal references like
Iron Man telling Captain America
look I'm not gonna get into an argument
with you this is not gonna end well
we've been down this road before then we
see what happens to rody because Captain
Marvel calls an audible she finds out
about Thanos doing something terrible
they never fully explained what it is
that Danis is doing only that he's gonna
do something terrible so Captain Marvel
is like we're gonna use Minority Report
to try and stop this so they take a team
but they get their asses handed to them
by Thanos in a couple a list characters
ends up dying so the stakes are already
really high
Ironman gets super pissed because he's
like I told you not to do this so now
you can kind of see why battle lines are
being drawn because Captain Marvel is
like we can still use Minority Report
because look at things like this big
celestial being here if we didn't know
about this before it was gonna happen
the earth would have been destroyed an
Iron Man is kind of like the great power
a great responsibility take caution
person in this situation so one let me
know in the comments what do you think
about Iron Man in this version of Civil
War is being the more sympathetic
character in Captain Marvel who's kind
of like the Superman version of Captain
America being the hardliner and - what
do you think the big twist is gonna wind
up being because Jean Grey is not able
to read Ulysses mind so I'm like there's
gotta be some twist here like the first
version of Civil War
Captain America ends up dying but it
turns into this secret Red Skull plot he
ends up getting reincarnated later so do
you think these dead characters will
stay dead for a long time remember this
is gonna go on for a while and if you
guys missed it there was actually an
Easter Egg for the Marvel movies in here
where war machine asks Ironman for a new
suit of armor he calls his war machine
armor Iron Man's 80s hand-me-downs
that's a line either from Iron Man 3 or
Captain America Civil War just the 80s
hand-me-down armor but as much of a
bummer as it is to see Rhodey go down I
mean they broke his spine and Captain
America's Civil War and now in the
comics they basically ripped it right
out like danos punches right through it
there is no way he is going to walk that
off I feel like that's the answer to
people not dying in the movies people
always complain the Marvel movies aren't
able to kill their a-list characters off
because there's such big franchises they
earned so much money on those movies but
the comics do not have that problem they
can kill anybody they want so r.i.p
Rhodey that's going to be like the new
a lifetime movie this summer Iron Man
not without my roadie coming to the
Lifetime channel next Wednesday but if
you guys haven't read it yet be sure to
check out Civil War 2 if you haven't
read DC rebirth yet you should read that
too if you don't read a lot of comics I
would at least recommend reading like
the big event comics this summer which
is Civil War 2 for Marvel and DC rebirth
my other favorite comic book right now
is the invincible Iron Man the
International Iron Man is also to
creatively the Iron Man comics are just
killing it right now but because Civil
War is like their big marquee event this
summer the artwork is just insane and
you look at this and you kind of
understand why they haven't surfaced
Captain Marvel in the movies yet she's
just so powerful that you have to put
her up against Thanos level villains
they explained it in Captain America
Civil War the reason why you didn't see
Thor in the Hulk is because they were
too powerful and they wanted it to feel
like people would be able to die like
most of the people involved in this are
a list Avengers but they're very human
and very killable when we get to thor
ragnarok you'll kind of see that play
out on screen little the threat level
will be that much bigger like Thor and
the Hulk will be fighting way more
powerful villains but let me know in the
comments if you guys want me to keep
doing comic book videos for Civil War
this summer and i will be doing a
guardians of the galaxy to video
tomorrow they started talking about the
villain they're talking about more
Planet Hulk things so just a whole bunch
of exciting Marvel stuff this week you
look at that panel and you just winced
like ooh that's gonna sting a little bit
but while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn all about the flash season 3
flashpoint they're adapting some of the
comic book storyline but not exactly and
you can click here to catch up on Game
of Thrones thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you